Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratis, and welcome to another week of HoloTalk for the week of April 10th, 2000.
Uh we're bringing a special show this week.
We have been running a series of shows that we recorded at the Center for the Holographic Arts in Long Island City, New York.
But we had some news come through that we've been waiting for for quite some time.
And I'd like to uh at least dedicate this program to that news.
Our special guest this week is going to be Franz Ross from Ross Books, and I'm joined right now with Michelle Roy once again in the studio.
Michelle, how are you doing?
I'm good, how are you?
Okay, because you're involved with this project to some extent as well.
Uh to quite a big extent in some areas that we'll get into in just a second.
Uh but what's happened is over the past year, or maybe a little bit more than a year, we've been work working with Ross Books, who has published the holography handbook and holography marketplace, to publish shoebox holography as a regular book.
As many of you know that shoebox holography was designed around the semiconductor lasers and a little system that students are using and even some amateurs and hobbyists uh to create holograms.
Franz Ross gave me a call and said they were interested in doing the book a little over a year ago, and since that time we've been working on it and now it's going to be released on April 14th and will be available in bookstores across the country and also your regular internet outlets such as Amazon.com, Barnes and Nobles, etc.
Michelle's involved with this to the point that you did a appendix to the book as far as uh career development with students.
And along that vein, what I'd like to do having you on uh the show right now is uh to get a f a few of your thoughts on how you feel that shoebox holography ties into the educational curriculum of a lot of the schools.
I think that one of the trends that we see in schools is that they're moving to more project oriented curricula where kids are rather than sitting and reading a book about lasers or holography or whatever, not that they don't need to read books, um, but actually having hands on experiences, particularly in the sciences, is incredibly important in terms of helping kids understand the underlying, you know, scientific principles and how everything works.
And I think the the great thing about the shoebox book is that it shows teachers and students, you know, step by step how to go through a project of creating a hologram that gives kids a real hands on experience with the technology and the scientific principles.
Plus the fact that a lot of schools are going to more interdisciplinary approaches where they're um having, you know, it's not just uh you know one subject on its own and there's so many, you know, math, physics, you know, all of those things tie into what you do with shoebox.
So, you know, that's a real opportunity for for teachers to do something that's not only project oriented um and hands on, but also uh interdisciplinary.
So it was the shoebox holography guide that allowed holography itself to become part of the uh state standards in Florida with communication technologies.
And the way that Bill Pugh and I worked on that was showing it was very important that we showed how other areas of education can tie in with the hit on uh different standards.
Um and mo and most states are moving to standards based education.
So if schools are looking for a way to you know have a unit, you know, in a science class or whatever that hits across multiple standards because many schools are complaining, well how the heck are we supposed to cover all of this, you know, in in a school year or over the course of a kid's um life in the schools, well this is something that hits across multiple standards and so those would you know be satisfied in one project.
Yeah.
Um so and by the end of this school year, I will have a program guide together for teachers w which will show them how they can bring a number of different students with different interests into this whole process and all center around the science and technology of shoe box holography.
Well, and you could even have teachers working together to on the you know you can have the teachers that have who have the same kids in the science class, you know, and and they work together so that it's actually the same kids.
Yeah.
Just in their different classes.
So we'll get that program to guide together for teachers as well, and you uh would be able to order that along with the shoebox holography uh book itself.
Also another area of the book that you wrote yourself.
The careers, right?
Careers and lasers.
Yeah, and you want to tell the uh little bit about it.
Yeah, I mean, very quickly, um one of the things that we wanted to do was um not was also look at how you know if kids found that they were interested or anyone found that they were interested in the whole uh field of lasers and photonics as a result of going through the shoebox holography, they could then explore uh different career options.
So that the appendix that I wrote basically talks about what are the different aspects that you have to consider in career development.
We did a show, you know, earlier in the season talking about that.
But then also has you know specific links to explore careers in lasers and photonics, links to education programs and so forth.
So that's all in that appendix so that if kids or whoever are interested in getting into a career, they could, you know, do some more exploration.
And I would like to thank you and Bill Freed and uh the Freedlance Group for Career and Workforce Innovation for providing the materials to go into the shoe box holography book, which will uh definitely be a great resource for teachers and educators and hobbyists if they would feel like they'd like to get more information, maybe even for a career change somewhere down the line.
All right, we're gonna move on to our interview with Franz Ross.
Uh friends is out in California, Ross Books, and like I'd mentioned before, they also published the holography handbook, which has been the Bible of holography for many, many years, and uh now they have shoebox holography, and once again it's going to be available through bookstores across the country and also through uh your internet outlets and also at the Holo World site.
You can order it there that we will have uh ordering at the Holo World site itself and it started off as that little guide that I put up on the web I think it was last March or something like that and uh they have what it's become.
Look what it's become.
That's good.
And hopefully we can bring kids into this field.
I'm getting emails uh about kids winning first place science fair yeah uh competitions and like the one that you showed me last night.
Oh yes Nyasa psyched and she got a special award from women in engineering.
Mm-hmm.
Okay, this is a little twelve year old uh kid you know young lady and uh may have a future in photonics uh laser communications points so that's how you know she was excited and we're very excited about don't want to use the show as something as a sales tool but uh as many of you know and have been listening for the past three years I rarely uh get on here to sell anything but this is something that's happening with holography and I just happen to be involved with it so I have to report on that as well.
So let's move on to our interview with Franz Ross.
Thank you for tuning in and I hope you tune in each and every week for a new HoloTalk show with uh myself and hopefully more visits with Michelle Riley.
Okay.
Thanks for tuning in.
Bye.
Hello Holo Talk listeners.
This is Frank Defratis and we have someone on the line here who needs no introduction at all.
It's uh Franz Ross from Ross Books publishing house of holography marketplace and holography handbook.
Franz how are you?
How are you doing Frank I'm doing great.
It's been a long road, hasn't it?
Yeah, it sure has.
Uh, you know, we've gone through a uh uh a lot of editions of the holography marketplace and we've got gone through a few uh you know, editions of the handbook and all.
And uh every time we come out with something we try to improve a little bit, you know.
Now we're doing shoebox holography.
Right, and that's very interesting the way that came up.
Um you know, we uh we produce the holography handbook and the uh uh the handbook explains to people how to go about building their own little studio and creating their own holograms at a fairly inexpensive uh amount of money.
But uh the feedback that we uh have been getting over time is that there still exists a a large number of people, uh particularly people that are uh right at the very, very beginning stage or or maybe in schools for example where they have extremely limited budgets.
Yeah.
And uh these people um have been coming back and saying that they just they can't get the authorization for the space or for the uh amount of money that's needed to go out and do a decent job of making uh a nice lab, you know, nice holograms.
Mm-hmm.
And uh so we're very excited about that.
And uh, you know, during the course of the development of the book, uh uh a high school teacher even uh called in as I understand and uh was became very excited about it and tried it out with the students and uh golly, you know, I I talked to the guy personally and he sent in like you know, lots of pictures of all the students running around making holograms and they're very involved with it.
They they enjoy it very much and it uh it seems like it fills a ne uh need, you know.
Yeah, yeah.
I imagine the book will be available in bookstores.
Oh yeah, it should be available uh uh this month, actually, April, probably toward the end of the month.
Mm-hmm.
And um, you know, we're really looking forward to it.
Very happy looking.
I know the book will be available online at your site, but will it also be available to people like through Amazon dot com and things?
Yes, as a matter of fact, we have a relationship with Amazon dot com.
And uh what Amazon wants us to do is uh as soon as we, you know, uh get the first books off the press to send it to them and they'll put it up there and uh it it'll be available at Amazon as well.
And um other places too, you know.
I mean, you know, we have relationships with uh library distributors and regular distributors, so it takes a while to get into the pipeline.
Uh it's the type of publication you might not find in every single bookstore because, you know, I mean it's not the kind of thing you make movies out of, you know.
Oh no, you could.
Yeah, I'm I'm sure we could make a movie out of this.
Has it been over a year?
Yeah, as a matter of fact it it it has taken about a year, hasn't it?
Yeah.
But uh, you know, I think it was time well spent, you know.
It's the kind of thing that uh you want to go back and forth on and uh you know, in the development of the book, you know, we tried a lot of different things, right?
Yeah, yeah, we did.
Um got me I I thought uh one of the things that uh uh took a little extra time was uh adding the uh fiber optic chapter, which I thought was uh really nice.
Uh yeah, we were we were contacted by John Clayer who's been on this show already and John does holograms inside of caves and he had mentioned that uh he was working on using the laser pointers to do fiber optic holograms.
So uh John worked with us and helped us uh get that chapter together and uh Steve Michael did a lot of the experimentation with that confirming the results and things as well.
Well the thing that really excites me about it, uh, you know, is just that uh it seems like if you're trying to uh introduce children to uh you know, or beginning people to holography, uh there's nothing more exciting than uh than seeing uh the light from the laser run through a little fiber optic tube and then that fiber optic tube be used to expose the uh the hologram itself.
Yeah.
You know, it uh and uh it's it's very interesting and very appealing.
And also showing the kids that this technology is used in everyday applications with communication technologies and that's something that they could actually grow up and move into that field as a career someday.
Right.
The really nice thing about it is that uh uh uh instructor or someone that uh brings this into their school and sets it up for you know, basically almost pocket change, you know, they are uh are able to bring in a lot of other disciplines, you know.
They can bring in uh fundamental optics, you know.
They can uh uh they can discuss fiber optics and uh how it's used in not only uh in making holograms here but also used in uh communications and so forth.
And um, you know, there are a lot of uh a lot of add-on uh disciplines that they can give fundamental uh lectures on and and introduction to.
And have a very wide group of uh students involved with it as well.
A lot of a lot of different applications there.
Yeah.
Yeah, there are a lot of different applications that you can find for it.
The really nice thing about it is that uh because it's at the uh at the beginning level, you don't have to be, you know, a physics student that's uh you know, you know, well along into the uh um instructional course in order to be able to appreciate it and and play with it.
It's more like a sort of uh uh introductory physics course type of uh uh of uh experiment.
The other really nice thing about it, uh this is the other feedback that uh we got from schools is that when you have something like uh making a hologram in a class, students are very interested in that because they get to put their hands on the objects, they get to move them around, they get to make something.
Yes.
And then when they're done with it they can actually walk out and go home with something.
Got a little show and tell item there.
And uh what we've found is that uh in an awful lot of the schools where this type of course is uh is allowed to be put on the curricula they they have a very large sign up, you know, and uh you know a great deal of interest in it.
Yeah.
And there's no doubt that the educational sector is going to be one of the biggest groups to benefit by shoebox holography, but another group also would be artists who did not want to initially make that large investment to experiment with holography.
Now they can actually just get started on their own at a very reasonable cost and see if it's something that they'd want to move on to.
That's exactly what I what I feel and uh the uh if it's done in a in a school setting well of course they can uh have the opportunity to discuss with other people that are like minded what they think about it and you know look at different resources and so forth and think about whether you know they want to move up to the next level and buy a a decent laser and what kind of laser is a decent laser.
Yeah.
And uh for individuals that want to do it at uh at home by themselves, I mean the the really good thing about it is that you're able to witness the phenomena, you know, and and see that it actually does work.
And uh it it's not uh a great cost to you the whole thing can be done, you know, less than a hundred dollars.
And um you know it um it uh gives you a feeling for uh what's involved in making a hologram so that you know you can then if you want to step up to the next level and build your own little studio or you know or do something a little more advanced.
Yeah.
It's sort of going to do for holography what the holography handbook did back when it was released.
Yeah I think that uh at the introductory level uh you know uh a lot of the people that were um uh that would look at the handbook and read through it and uh um and say to themselves I'm really interested but the problem is I I can't quite justify to myself the uh uh the space and uh the money well th those people will be captured I mean or will you know w will still be able to uh be introduced to the field of holography by doing uh you know the shoe box holography experiment.
Is it spiral bound?
Yeah actually it's spiral bound so that uh you know you can turn to any individual page and uh have it just you know lie flat so that uh you can use it as a recipe book.
Yeah.
And in fact uh I think that uh you and Steve and uh great length to make sure that uh the exposures and all are are you know reasonably accurate.
Of course everybody uh understands that uh diode lasers uh which are very inexpensive, you know the laser pointers are are not the same that's a you know uh uh you know a powerful CW laser or or very expensive laser.
But they are capable of of producing the uh exposures.
And um you know what what this book does is it uh it gives you a specific emulsion, a sh a specific exposure and uh you know distances and everything that you need so that you can produce the product.
Yes.
And without that, you know, there would be an awful lot of uh um disappointment, I think, on the part of a lot of people.
Now you had mentioned to me that April fourteenth some of the books will be ready off of the press.
When would someone be able to order this for themselves?
Well, they can actually order the book now, since we're only one about a week or so away here.
And uh any order that is uh received, you know, will, you know, be filled immediately.
It will be one of the first orders filled.
So I mean you should get the book within a couple of weeks, you know, and we should ship within a couple of weeks.
Okay.
Well, I guess it's a uh a time for celebration now that we're finally finished with this project, and it was a great experience for me to be able to work on a project like this, and I want to thank you very much for the opportunity to uh put shoebox holography out there.
Well, I just I want to thank you an awful lot for what you're doing, Frank.
You're doing a great deal for the holography community.
I don't think there's anyone else that does as much as what you do.
And uh I think this book is uh you're just the right author for it because uh uh these are your people.
I mean, they're just uh it's uh gives a real good introduction to the field of holography.
I'm sure people will be very happy with it.
Okay.
Well, thank you very much for taking the time to come on Holotalk.
Thank you very much for having me.
And hang on the line, I want to talk to you after I close out here.
See you next week, everyone.
Remember we have guests each and every week.
Uh next week we're going to continue our program with the uh recordings that we did at the Center for the Holographic Arts in Long Island City, New York.
And I hope you tune in then.
Take care.
Bye.